fallout 4 automaton DLC is out now but  that's not the only update available for  Bethesda's latest game survival mode is  now available on PC and you can opt into  the beta on Steam just be prepared for a  very different game Fallout 4 survival  mode is built on four pillars strategy  exploration resource management and  role-playing that means you're dealing  with harder combat no fast traveling or  quick saving managing your appetite and  hydration and avoiding fatigue and only  real beds will let you get a full  night's rest all of this comes alongside  new bug fixes and stability improvements  those apply to the main game as well as  the automaton DLC the survival mode beta  is out now on PC and it's coming to ps4  and Xbox one in April that's the same  month fallout 4s wasteland workshop  add-on is releasing so you shouldn't run  out of Commonwealth to explore anytime  soon for now you can keep it long to  gamespot for all the fallout news you  need  you